on the stage today and I'd mean that
literally
we have Daenerys we have Sarah we have
Jon Snow we have Chilean to name but a
few
all very much on the edge of something
disastrous happening the mood is somber
it's you know world's leaders uniting
and disagreeing about how the world
should be run it can go south very
quickly and that's brilliant part of
that the sequence because you know how
quickly things can turn on this show
that's a potential powder keg so no
matter what's happening no matter who's
meeting who the potential for things to
completely explode is always there the
dragon pit is probably one of the most
essential scenes sequences in all Game
of Thrones Tyrion and his posse they
know they're entering a dangerous place
and they know they're taking a risk
coming here you have 60 Plus hours at
this point of main characters who you
are really invested in and it's
enjoyable to put people together who
haven't been together before and see how
they would react to each other it's
people becoming aware of their the
smallness I think in their nature no
matter how much they fight each other
there's a bigger threat to life than
just who's on the throne you can say to
anyone you know this disease is coming
but until you can show them evidence
they won't get past their own smaller
problems to fight the big problem these
things build over time in that 50 70
hours to get to this point it takes 70
hours for for the story to allow this
scene to happen there's a momentum
that's up now which doesn't stop so it's
that's really exciting
it's incredible because I am the new kid
on the block and I've seen these guys
for six seasons now then all of a sudden
being part of their scene
I think this is gonna be one of the
scenes of this season the dragon pit
epitomizes the central challenge of
season seven where we have a dozen four
principal characters all in the same
place many of whom haven't seen each
other since a very dramatic incident
years before between them so that scene
was incredibly tricky to write an
incredibly tribute of film you want to
be able to service all of these
characters and that was tremendously fun
to plot out conflicts between people
friendships between people which ones
you wanted to highlight which ones that
you're gonna have to let fall by the
wayside you have you know dozens of
seems like dozens of little mini scenes
so we had to find great moments and
character interactions and story for all
of these characters it was just so much
fun to write for all these guys together
it kind of forced us to really explore
what the different tonal variations were
in those reunions
you know it's trying to keep an eye on
what they're all there for I mean
they're all there for a reason which is
to discuss the possibility of an
alliance and whether that's even
possible with these people who have so
many reasons for hating each other and
so a few reasons for trusting each other
welcome my Lords for poured the seat
Elian I mean that guy was the most
important person in the world to him he
was the only person who'd given him a
chance I'm glad you're alive there's
something very sweet in it and amongst
all the big stuff the small stuff still
happens as well and that's what adds to
the texture of the show I think that
stuff's never forgotten about what's in
there [ __ ] off
there's a really wonderful moment where
Brienne spies The Hound and she realizes
that she has to sort of apologize
maybe maybe for nearly killing him maybe
but she also brings to him the news that
she knows he wants to hear that Arya is
alive and is home oh that was a relief
yeah of course and a concern is she all
right
he's protecting earth you're here the
only one that needs protecting is the
one that gets no way and then it turns
out that we don't need to worry about
Arya because I've taught her everything
what I love about Tyrion and bronze
relationship is they know exactly who
they are
Tyrion prods him a little bit how much
bran is doing things that have
self-interested don't you worry about me
I'm doing all right
looking after myself are you helping me
to arrange this meeting wasn't exactly
looking after yourself was it it's your
head queen Circe's offer the bag of gold
force not mine
knocks on his tin heart a little bit
knows there's something in there it's
good to see you again
I dare you to you have surcease ink
tyrion for the first time in a long time
her mortal enemy so the first time they
lock eyes when she walks in that's a
moment it's really awkward it's like the
movie
I know family reunions for everyone are
very awkward but let's just say the
Lannisters are a complicated Bunch she's
held him responsible the death of her
mother and the death of Joffrey and her
father you know she can't really take
responsibility we'll deal with her own
grief she has to just blame everybody
else and that's part of her pain too
Lina gives me a look that I never want
to see ever again it's yeah it very
might almost flattened me I wanted to
hide me my brother how is good
I had a standoff with him which was
great fun that was great ignoring it a
very serious situation behind just to a
straight two amigos basically you and me
pal we haven't finished you're getting
there there's a nonverbal four or five
second thing between Cersei Jaime and
Brienne that's not even a line of
dialogue it's just a little mini scene
of built out of looks it's sort of like
one of the worst things that happens to
you at school I think it's Brienne's
idea of absolute abject hell fighting
the Hound was an abject hell but a
moment of having to deal with Jaime and
Cersei is the most excruciating thing
that could possibly happen to Brienne
she arrives with the mountain and Jaime
and then they say the Kings gone and
she's you know pretty fierce and then
she realizes that Danny isn't here and
that pisses her off obviously and
of course Danny I was on dragon you know
I take fashion be late - brand-new eyes
she's very theatrical with her entrance
though it's kind of funny that go wow
she really has to show off her power
but fair enough and she tries
desperately to not be impressed by that
arrival when everyone else obviously as
you were just standing up in all of this
and then you know in books this young
beauty of a queen and she's immediately
beyond frustrated on many levels we've
been here for some time my apologies and
then all she gets from Danny is
apologies you know and that then drives
her in the scene and she can't bear it
we have something to show you
for me being a Hornet
I was slightly giggly though but my very
young zombie
she has never ever seen anything like
this before and this is a creature that
defies her this is a creature she
doesn't know how to disable she doesn't
know how to kill this is something else
Daenerys has seen it and she's aware of
it in its frightening but she is just
watching Cersei like she just needs to
know that this has affected her you know
she's always had that notion of
creatures like this that they don't
exist and it's nonsense and so I think
when he's there she's she's back as a
kid just the you know realizing
everything her her grandma her nannies
told her was real she's staring into
a face that she never thought existed
for Jamie this is like definite proof
that they have there is no choice
clearly this thing we have to deal with
us in and then he believes them all he
believes his brother but he also
believes Daenerys and Jon Snow and when
they say that they saw one hundred
thousand of these beings
that's where his head is you know the
world could end in five minutes but he
is absolutely one-pointed focused on I
have never seen this before this is
amazing I could really do this you know
there's this beat in the scene that I
really love because I have a line waked
where he's like he just seemed the white
Walker just died and you realizes just
the first thing he's ever seen that
terrifies him and that's like a new
emotion for him you know oh I was I was
that was an interesting feeling
I'm going back to my island you should
go back to yours when winters over we'll
be the only ones left alive and it all
rests her dragons death everything
everything rests on Jon Snow just lying
the crown accepts your truce in return
the king in the north will extend this
truce he will remain in the north where
he belongs
he will not take up arms against the
Lannisters he will not choose sides they
kill a plan of action and then it all
kind of falls apart with Jon's
honor again if I come on dude like it's
all you got to do just this one time
just tell a fib and he can't he just
can't like that was the bad move that
was a bad choice but thanks so much
I am true to my word or I try to be that
is why I cannot give you what you ask I
cannot serve two Queens
Tyrion knowing his sisters so well knows
that that's not gonna go over well and
of course it doesn't
and when Jon does that the whole thing
crumbles so it's sort of like I get it
but then there is nothing left to
discuss
it is so much fun
with all of us all together having been
isolated for so long and then suddenly
boom I'm working with everybody was
quite kind of event for me it was I
loved it it's lovely it's all of us
being together so we all kind of fit oh
that was really exciting because we are
all just a big happy family and that
extended to after work unfortunately
because we had way too much fun you know
usually a like like you Yun said and
then you have one AK of other actors to
hang out with suddenly were like 15 10
15 at the same hotel it was just a
recipe for disaster but it was fun
though having been so invested in the
show for so long for so many years it's
just so thrilling and I was personally
very excited to finally meet Daenerys
and I hope for the fans that they see a
satisfying realization of what I think
they will be maybe waiting for these for
these worlds to be collided those 10
days were 10 of the most enjoyable days
I've ever spent doing this show because
it's all these people it's having such
an excellent time just being in each
other's company I will never forget
those days and on that set they were
outstanding
you